would you say that 99 of all movies
today
are garbage
in an age where most movies are referred
to as
content i would say that 99 of most
movies
are pretty are pretty bad i always try
to like when when i say
99 i mean of mainstream it really is
when you look at
and especially i think one of the best
examples of this is the sort of
uh zach snyder's justice league
and how that was you know bungled
the the that how that was bungled how
the star wars franchise
was bungled how they could not i mean
to me i i i'm the studio executive in
charge of star wars
and we're making a new star wars movie
and the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to put
han luke and leia in a scene together
and the fact that that moment
we will never be able to have that
moment in cinema when carrie fisher was
alive
that to me is i mean
that's that's malpractice that's studio
malpractice the fact that they had with
zack snyder's vision what he was
building up to be
i think seeing the four-hour final
product of what zack snyder's justice
league
turned out to be and that they made this
garbage thing joss whedon
i mean it's it's disheartening to me to
see that
um i will say on an indie level i tend
to take like a glass half full view
and i tend to always look for the
positive when it comes to indie films
because you cannot compare the the
the um you can't compare an indie movie
shot in 12 days for 10 000 dollars
to justice league whichever version
you're talking about you can't compare
because in my mind
there is no excuse for a studio to fail
when they put out a blockbuster movie
you have no excuse your job is to
entertain me
not lecture me not lecture me
your job is to entertain me
unfortunately we live in a time
you know back in the day when star wars
was first made
i feel like they were checking one box
it was called fun
and now there's not only there's a
million
boxes that must be checked there are all
sorts of
noting and committees and this thing and
this is where you
end up with um you know that last star
wars movie by jj abrams is unwatchable i
mean it's it's it's
garbage it's it's it's exactly
it informs exactly everything wrong with
the studio system
it's it's terrible so i look at like the
the the justice league
debacle the the the star wars
franchise and how that has been was
mishandled
and i look at that and and i just think
how could that have been done where were
the
where where was the they're ever like
looking at like the fans and what they
think
you know um what do the fans think of
this stuff are they satisfying the fans
most normal people don't
care you know like like is it
entertaining taking my family especially
how expensive it is to the movie theater
experience which
is is going away right the theatrical
experience of seeing a movie
um is is going away you had better
entertain me
um and i think that whether hollywood
notices it or not
i think that people don't really like
politics woven into
fairly mainstream which should be
mainstream entertainment experiences
um and i think we're we're seeing that
more and more
it's it's unbelievable to me i think
you're leaving money on the table
um for for not giving what the customer
is looking for in that experience but
um so in my mind studios there's no
excuse to fail you have the best people
in marketing
you have the most talented actors
craftsmen when it comes to special
effects and cinematography
music there's no excuse for that to fail
and i think
part of the failing of hollywood is that
the marketing is so good sometimes
i've i've argued with friends sometimes
that i believe that that there should be
a key art i mean there are key art
awards
you know for key movie poster art i'm a
fan of movie poster art there's a
really good documentary about movie
poster art called 24x36
check out that documentary um but
you know there there should almost be a
a marketing award
and here's the problem the conundrum
the marketing for some for these movies
is so good
the product doesn't live up to the
marketing so
i mean i got chills watching the
trailers
for the rise of skywalker i was so
excited to see that movie
the ninth i mean i was a kid when i saw
star wars i'm seeing the ninth movie in
this saga
i cannot believe how horrible it turned
out
it's it's it's really to me it's
malpractice
what happened to that franchise and how
it's divided fandom
fighting over things that are really
irrelevant i
i think i think it's it's well
not entirely irrelevant the fact that
they're just like you're seeing people
from within that company attack the fans
it's just like it's
i i hate to see it because i'm like
nerds are my people i go to san diego
comic-con every year i have since the
90s
gone to san diego comic-con and so to
see people fractured over this is really
is really disheartening but
um when it comes to studio movies
there's no excuse not to fail
now when it comes to small indie movies
to make a good movie under those
circumstances without the resources
without the money without the
great people in marketing without the
budget
without all of the best of circumstances
to make an indie movie that like
actually can can you can be touched and
moved by
that is something to be said which is
why i've always gravitated toward indie
film
you know um it's a miracle when you see
something that's
that's watchable out of a studio um
but i don't i i don't know like where
the executives
i mean other than like maybe coming to
mind like a kevin feige which
you know maybe his best days are behind
him
you know i can't think of a studio
executive that is a visionary
these days are those the jocks the nerds
or the nerds of the
consumers yeah the jocks yeah i mean
when we
look at like the era the the the 70s
being the
the um last great era of american
filmmaking we really are
um losing that american identity because
we become so fractured as a culture and
i think that that
you know where's the movie that we all
love without debate
that we've all loved
exactly i don't know that there is one
and and that's really
you know i i really and and at the end
of the day i miss
loving star wars i miss loving it i used
to love it
and now i'm saddened by that franchise
i'm using that as like the best example
there's a lot of other
examples we could talk about the
terminator franchise we could talk about
star trek
we can talk about these these sort of
dead franchises that
um have sort of lost their way but when
you look at like i just saw a
documentary called
lady laddi about alan ladd
the visionary studio executive who
basically
greenlit star wars and protected george
lucas
i'm just afraid we're never going to see
another george lucas right we're never
going to see
another real creative visionary um that
changes the industry because
everything is so corporate you know it's
like what did francis ford coppola say
factory filmmaking that's that's the age
in which we live
there's factory filmmaking which is a
product and content
and then there's up and coming indie
filmmakers
and you know when i talked about
checking those boxes earlier a lot of it
is like is it going to appeal
international i mean let's
let's be honest the box office
internationally and especially in china
is much bigger than the united states
that market those dollars
so you can't make a movie for the united
states anymore you have to make
a movie for the world which is fine but
i think in in a way
that's sort of diluting our identity as
as a people as americans as we become
more fractured and it's um
it's distressing to see you know you you
see it when it's like
when it's like god i was having a
conversation with a friend
uh because of course the movies are
always an ongoing conversation with
friends
um if you're in my circle you'll it it
will
come up and it's like when you look at
like when certain decisions are organic
or when you see when it's shoe horned in
right shoe when when certain things are
shoe horned in like
um like a say the the
trope that's become a trope now the
strong female lead it's just ripley
was a great character like just write a
great character
not try to shoehorn in a type right and
you kind of know it when you see it you
go oh this is cliche this is a
you're trying to shoehorn in a type
rather than like that's just a great
character you're also talking to a guy
when i ever play
a video game i always choose a female
character i don't know why i just do
that
as someone who has watched so many
movies as someone who has
made their own films why do you think
there's so many bad films that are made
well i look the reason there's so many
bad films
um these days is i think
well one the barrier to entry is is much
easier but i also think that you're
they're on that that's on an indie level
i see bad indie films too right i
usually want to want to help them
and say this was your lesson okay you'll
make a better movie in your second movie
if you don't quit
but when it comes to studio films
there's just too many notes there are
too many people that
um it's sort of you know the modern day
ball player right like it's just like
it's not about the passion for playing
the game i don't have a passion of
you know hitting the ball and hearing
the roar of the crowd it's
you know it's the licensing deals and
it's this and the sales of that and the
tv commercials and whatnot it's
it's um you know
i i i when i look back at the movie the
player which came out when i
first moved to los angeles robert
altman's the player
things haven't changed the subject has
changed i mean that was
sort of it was erotic thrillers and you
know it was julia roberts and bruce
willis
were being cast in every movie that was
pitched in that film
now it's superhero movies but it's
really too many cooks and i feel like
the people being
um you know elevated to these positions
are good executives but they're not
people that know the material the heart
of the material and when you look at the
history of
you know um creatives who really created
something
like a george lucas or a gene
roddenberry
things begin to lose their way when they
get sidelined right
you really need those i just i i feel
like the modern
day hollywood now and especially with
streaming
changing the game theaters
the survival of theaters being in doubt
um really we may
live at a time where maybe the billion
dollar blockbuster may not be
back for a long time and that may end up
being a good thing
right like let's let's make
it's i always i'll joke with a friend
and i'll say my favorite spider-man
movie is the one where mary jane is in
peril at the end
which is pretty much all the spider-man
movies or my favorite science fiction
movie is the movie where that thing
blows up at the end
that's every science fiction movie right
which is why and the empire strikes back
with such a because it wasn't about we
got to do and blow up the thing
that's boring it's
it's just creatively bankrupt which is
why empire strikes back
holds up everybody says oh it's the best
star wars movie i mean you could argue
but it
but um it's yeah because it didn't do
that thing that happened in all the
other movies
and and so trying to go against
doing that thing it's it's or
fighting a blue light there's a lot of
fighting a blue light that happens
um in films fighting a blue light
saving the person at the end the thing
that blows up at the end
and i say defy those cliches
at all costs um
and it's funny because you see like you
know there's still people that are able
to work within
studio system and deliver worthwhile
films um
christopher nolan being among them i've
um quite
admired his work although he has a
tendency to make things a little overly
complex for no reason just to brag
about how smart he is but there's always
a point in his films and you'll notice
it once i pointed out where
a character in a christopher nolan movie
will say we have to go down the thing
and grab the thing to do this
and shoot this it's it's captain
narrative right
it's the person that stops the movie to
tell you what's happening in the movie
to explain what's going to happen so the
audience the dumb audience understands
and to me
oh so you got that studio now studio
note and he compromises in a way that
doesn't completely
destroy what he's trying to achieve as a
filmmaker
so he's willing to play ball but
i just see and i think you know the most
recent example being zack snyder's
justice league and the fact that that
universe will remain unexplored
unfortunately
um which is disheartening uh uh
you look at that and i think part of the
reason that zack snyder's justice league
was suppressed was because
you know once it came out and you see
these are the choices the studio
executives made they
decided to hire joss whedon they decided
to change
everything about it in in you know in
exchange for this like
it makes them look bad right because
what zack snyder was trying to do is
much much better
um clearly whether you enjoy it
personally or not
it was objectively much better than what
joss whedon ended up coming up with
which was
effectively a dumb cartoon a live action
dumb cartoon
so what about adaptations do you think
that that's
has that always been around or is that
adaptations adaptations of popular books
not not necessarily doesn't have to be a
franchise but you know well i mean think
about
think about it it's here's what's dead
is originality i mean
people forget what george lucas created
in star wars was something completely
original
i mean yes it was influenced by so many
things
westerns you know flash gordon and buck
rogers cereals and whatnot
but but almost nothing
that you see isn't nothing that you see
in the studio realm
it's all based on something pre-existing
material
it's a book a graphic novel a comic book
a thing that kind of proved the concept
right and then or a franchise right it's
a thing that
you know whether it's star wars star
trek whatever
um you know comic book characters that
have been around for years
it's very rare that there'll be
something that's a wholly original
concept
um so i kind of uh you know i
i i i really it would really be
interesting if studios rolled the dice
more
to get something like a joker what todd
phillips did with the joker right
that joker film which was a low-budget
movie
right i mean um i chatted with him about
it i'm sure you can
look up quotes todd phillips talking
about how he he pitched them doing some
sort of dc black series
it would be these sort of one-off films
that would be stories
that didn't really fit with any sort of
larger continuity
that were like smaller movies we could
explore a part of that universe
um and the fact that that movie did so
well you know from
being praised from uh uh you know in
terms of at award season i think is
um proves his concept was was the right
way to go
and people forget todd phillips came
from independent film
you know he i knew him back in the day
when he was making documentaries
he famously has that frat house
documentary that played sundance and
then never was released
so um i think you can find it on youtube
um
what about mink what's that what about
mink mink yeah i don't know how you make
a mink you know
like here's the thing i look at mank and
i'm like i
love mank but i went to film school
and i've seen citizen kane 100 times and
i've read books about citizen kane and
one of my one of my favorite dvd
commentaries is the one that roger ebert
did
for citizen kane um so i know a lot of
the backstory
and i feel like it's almost impossible
to watch mank you have to watch citizen
kane
maybe watch citizen kane first and then
watch mank
and then re-watch citizen kane um but
yeah i think
mank is incredible you know um
but i think it's for i think mank is for
film nerds
i mean i think it's brilliant that david
fincher was able to
get that film made in the way that he
made it
you know it's sort of an it's sort of a
story about the genre
made within the style of the old school
genre
but with modern tools and then sort of
laced with political
commentary maybe a bit too heavy-handed
at times
but i really enjoyed mank
but it's not that's not a mainstream
audience movie
so kudos to uh kudos to netflix
for that um but yeah most of i wouldn't
say that no
you know i like to be an optimist so i
don't know that 99
of the studio movies are bad maybe it's
more like 97.
um we can we can quibble about the
percentages but
you know stuff leaks through
that was a rant by the way no that's
good that's what you want
that's fantastic i was going to add to
it with game of thrones but that's good
we'll stop okay